so let's say i was preparing to go on a
long hike
besides packing water dressing for the
weather and mapping my route i'd
probably also want to eat a snack before
leaving to make sure i have enough
energy for the hike
we as humans need food to nourish our
bodies but how exactly does that food
give us energy how does something like
an apple or a piece of chocolate get
converted into something our bodies can
use the answer to this question can be
found in a process called cellular
respiration which is how organisms get
their energy from food in other words
cellular respiration helps make life
possible it's happening right now in
your cells and in mine in my little
brother's pet hamster cells and in the
cells of the tree outside the window
it's providing all of us with the energy
that we need to function
so let's dive into this process to find
out more about how it works
cellular respiration is a series of
chemical reactions that happen in an
organized way inside our cells it's
these chemical reactions that result in
an overall release of energy that our
bodies can use
although cellular respiration involves
many chemical reactions this entire
process for plants and animals can be
summarized here by this equation
on the left side of this equation are
the inputs glucose which is a type of
sugar and oxygen glucose comes from our
food and oxygen comes from the air we
breathe
the right side of this equation shows
the outputs carbon dioxide and water the
arrow in the middle shows that during
the process of cellular respiration
glucose and oxygen molecules are broken
apart and their atoms are rearranged to
eventually form carbon dioxide and water
this whole process releases energy
similar to how firewood releases energy
as it burns also no atoms are lost
during cellular respiration you can see
the same number of each type of atom on
both sides of the arrow for example six
carbon atoms on both sides it's similar
to how you could take apart a brick
house and use those bricks to build
something else like a bridge you're not
throwing away any of the bricks but
instead you're creating something new
out of them
so we know that cellular restoration
involves a series of chemical reactions
but where in the cell do these steps
happen
to find out let's walk through the
process together after eating your food
is broken down into small molecules
during digestion
these small molecules which include
glucose can enter your cells
then cellular respiration can begin the
first set of chemical reactions happen
in the cytosol which is the jelly-like
fluid containing all of the cell's
organelles and they involve glucose as
an input the rest of the reactions
happen in mitochondria
with oxygen as an input and carbon
dioxide and water as outputs together
these chemical reactions result in an
overall release of energy
it might be a little mind-boggling for
you to think about how the food we eat
provides the energy our bodies need to
carry out all of life's processes and i
know it was for me
after all it's not every day you take a
bite of an apple and wonder how that
apples molecules are rearranged inside
your body what's important to know
though is that cellular respiration is
the way our cells get usable energy
through cellular respiration you and i
get the energy that we need to do the
things we want to do including
accomplishing our goals so the next time
you feel proud of yourself for finishing
a big hike or acing your biology quiz
make sure to thank your mitochondria